we would now like to generalize the
work-energy theorem to more than one
dimension remember that we defined our
work as an integral from A to B of a
force dot DS and graphically let's look
at that as if we started a and we go to
a point B and if at some point on this
path we have a force F and the
displacement is always tangent to the
force for an object M we would like to
now figure out how this integral is
related to the change in kinetic energy
so first off it's always important when
analyzing a new result to understand
where Newton's second law comes in and
for our point particle Newton's second
law is that the force is equal to MA
which we can write as mass times the
derivative of the velocity and so our
first step is to rewrite the work
integral and now to incorporate Newton's
second law into this integral so this is
no longer simply a concept of physics
but it's combining the second law and
our definition of work now what I'd like
to do here is to note that any the
Veloster displacement of a particle is
always equal to the velocity times DT so
if we put that result in here
a B of M DV DT dot V DT you can see that
we can cancel d TS which is essentially
taking the time out of this integral and
writing the work entirely in terms of
the small change in velocity DV scalar
product with the velocity and this is
the quantity we know would now like to
calculate so one way when we ever want
to calculate these dot products we
choose a coordinate system so let's
choose a Cartesian coordinate system
plus X plus y with our unit vectors I
had
and j-hat and now our task is to write
down these various vectors so for
instance DV can be written as DV X I hat
plus DV Y J hat now if we were to go
into three dimensions we would have DV Z
K hat but I'm just going to do this in
two dimensions similarly the velocity is
VX I hat plus V Y J hat and now when we
take the dot product as we've learned in
Cartesian coordinates it's just the
components DV X DX and I'll just do a
little parenthesis there plus DV Y dy
and so now our work integral a b is
equal to the mass times DV x DX plus the
mass times DV y dy now what we have here
is - a sum in the integrand but by the
rules of integration we can rewrite this
integral as two separate integrals from
A to B of M DV X VX and from A to B of M
DV y v1 and now we can integrate each of
these separately and if you recall in
one dimension we used our integral
formula this is just VX squared and when
we integrate them what we have to look
at is the endpoints of our integral it's
what we're integrating is the velocity
and we're going from some initial value
to some final value
so our first integral simply becomes M
VX final squared I'll pull out the
factor 2 minus VX initial squared where
a DX initial is the
so X component of velocity at a and VX
final is the final component of B and I
have a similar term here which is V Y
final squared minus V y initial squared
and when I combine our terms VX final
squared plus V Y final squared minus 1/2
m VX initial squared plus B Y and your
sole squared we've already shown that
our kinetic energy one-half M VB is
one-half MV x squared plus B Y squared
and so we see that this is just the
final kinetic energy minus the initial
kinetic energy and so we can call that
Delta K and what we have now is the work
energy theorem and I'll come back to my
original statement that the work is
equal to the change in kinetic energy
and this is a combination of our
definition of work and Newton's second
law